T
PROGRAM WERCANCELED
CHT ETORIOUY D
UEREALLY TO WE GETTOMONTS ER
SHOOTING PINK WAS NATO BEAT
EIR CRARPARTIES E
POWERFULFFIT WASKED IN
THEY'RE VERYRENEO
, ESPECIALLY TAI
S  W
CORIS.IS IS DARKABOUT.
E'S MEBETHIS CS,US ABOUT THIS
S GNQUEST.
ERT DEGREE.
NOW,AY IS THE
AND M
MEMBERS.
E F LLN PEOPLE.
BYP R YOUR KAREN, POTENTIALLY,E
E D BEENUTIONALIZED
PARTD,
HI
SHARING, MOC
NE.
CA.ERE PROVINCES OR ILOSELY SHPI
M
CKS CHIEOF
Y.
REGARDLECAPABILITY
AFFINITY ANDOY PARTICU L
LARGESTHE TIME OFCERTAIN TCHINA
THISRAISING SOMEUNIQUE CHALLENGB
COVID POLI
HE IBECAME
CHIEF BECAUSEAS
DOESN'T MATTER.
ENHAI TAIWAN, WHAT
EXIST ARIC THEIR
TERM
THSAME LANGUAGE TH WE'VE
HEARFOP HAASPINGYE
GS LIKBEIJING MUSTTSCOERCI
AN THAT THEIR
AUNL TEHRANES SOVEREIGNTY, FRMS
OW OWNLITARY.
ITRE AND
DEAGWHAT IPERCEIVED AS A
CUT AWJINPI
REPORTHILESH AND
F MILITARYIN TAIWAN WHENOU
CURSIONS ITHZOY THTA AFTER THE K
STEP UP MILITARY ERRE IN TAAN E
TH F WOF ANALYSTS BELIEV AAB YOT
F  ISLAND
BECAUSBEINT
TAIWAN IPACHLE ITY BOWDON'T
TAIWANESE. IDENTIFY
NIO
T IS NOTED A
ECAUSE OPOLITICAL
SUS .
S ENUP.
BUHEVEO ONE, THA LE'S BEEN A RKF
K TO POU IS ATEHRFROM CHINA?
MOVED HERE,
S  EAR TNO, ABA  MORT TALK TO
NOEA
PEN.
IFICANT OM W